we're live chairman
thank you
good evening members and welcome to
rockford district council's remote
meeting of the executive
and welcome to anyone watching this via
live stream
and also welcome to other members but
not members of the executive
so with that hey welcome to everyone
on friday the 9th of april we will
receive the very sad news of the passing
of his royal highness
prince philip duke of edinburgh
in line with guidance issued by the
government the council will continue to
provide services
and conduct its business during the
national period of mourning
we have lowered our flag to half-mast as
a mark of respect
and will be streaming a two-minute
silence on friday the 16th of april
at 9 30 a.m residents will be able to
follow this live
the link will be on the front page of
the council website
for that point we'll move to agenda item
one
apologies for absence and no apologies
have been received since everyone is
actually
present here's an either thank you
sonia if you'd be kind enough to read
out the names of any
non-members of the executive attending
please
yes chairman um we have councillors
gooding sparing and mrs shaw
chairman thank you sonya
moving to agenda item 3 the minutes of
the meeting
on the 3rd of march they've been
circulated
and can i ask if they are agreed please
members
great great agreed great
great thank you very much
those are agreed
moving on to item four if i can take any
declarations of interest
are there any uh to declare please on
any items on the agenda this evening
no i'm not seeing any hands or any uh
other than in the negative so thank you
very much indeed
item five is questions on notice from
councillors
and no questions have been received for
this evening's meeting
gender item six matters referred to the
executive
reports from other committees there are
none
members so that takes us nicely on to
agenda item at
seven which is the parks for nature
initiative
at the portfolio holder for environment
and place counselor arthur williams will
present the report please
arthur thank you chairman and thank you
members
this report sets out an opportunity an
opportunity to consider how watchful
councils open spaces
and parks can help meet the council's
carbon neutral targets
and at the same time improve parts for
the benefit of wildlife
and of course residents appended to this
report is the parks for nature paper
reviewed by the carbon net neutral
member working group
this sets out the principles of
incorporating environmental friendly
improvements
into the parks and open spaces paragraph
3.6 of the report provides a summary of
those principles
the most significant of which focus on
increasing the tree cover
and relaxing of mowing any proposed
changes to the parks will be explored
and consulted upon
through a series of site visits that
io's portfolio holder will be attending
and the respective board members also
invited
further consultation will also be
undertaken with parish council and
residents
it is anticipated that i will be
presenting a further report to the
executive in july
setting up the feedback to the
consultation and proposing to finalize
plans
for the delivery of park for nature
initiative
of course if you have any questions we
will do our best to answer them and i'd
like to thank
members of the working party and also ad
marcus holden for all of the hard work
to prepare this report thank you very
much
thank you councillor williams uh at that
point i'll take any questions
any reference to uh references within
the report
are there any questions for councillor
williams
or assistant director marcus hoffman
councilman sparrowing um
you are not actually a member of the
committee
so i don't really think i can take a
question sorry about that
um right are there any other members of
the executive that wish to
raise make a question raise a question
i'm not seeing any indication
which takes us on to the recommendation
and there's just one recommendation set
out of paragraph 1.1
on page 7.1 of the report and i'll read
that out to approve
the approach outlined in this report to
adapt and improve parts and green spaces
and contribute to the council commitment
to make rockford district council
carbon neutral by 2013.
members i will move this recommendation
do i have a second of these
i'll second that chairman thank you
thank you councillor
so moving on to the voting uh please
unmute yourself and advise me if you're
not able to use the electronic hand and
raise your hand
manually so it can be counted if
anyone would like a recorded vote to be
taken please click on the race hand icon
once if you wish to have a recording
vote
and i'm not seeing any uh
raised hand icons so
now voting on the recommendation
voting will be done by the electronic
show of hands all those in favor of the
recommendations
please click on the raise and icon once
please
chairman that's unanimous and that is
unanimous
and approved
moving on then to item agenda item
number
eight if i can ask the portfolio holder
for commercial
business local economy and leisure
councillor danielle
belton who will present the report
please
councillor belton
thank you chairman and thank you marcus
for putting together a particularly
thorough
report on this item essentially
the recommendation is for rockford
council to enter a framework agreement
with
um essex county council to allow
rochford businesses to
access some additional business grant
funding
now as per 0.3.4 the outlined expected
funding available to rochford businesses
will be in the region of 230
000 pounds now to be clear this is in
addition to the circuit
22 million that has been
other schemes this is a specific we can
access for our businesses
the grants can be administered by a
budgeting
council and this is at no cost to
rochefort district so although the f the
front facing will be
via rochford council essentially
it's a it's a low risk opportunity for
our businesses to
access some additional support at this
difficult time
thank you thank you councillor belton
are there any questions for councillor
belton
or indeed assistant director marcus
hoffman
councillor ward yeah thank you very much
leader
um it's just a clarification just to
make sure we know that
it's about basildon who are actually
administering
uh this but everything actually will go
through rochford district and that can
be confirmed please
yes i can confirm that unless marcus you
want to add to anything in addition
no i mean it's informative that's what
needs to be said really
thank you council award thank you uh
council belton uh councillor smith uh
thank you chairman i just suffered a
little bit of breakup during councillor
belton's
uh words just for the sake of clarity
could you just restate
how much money we've already paid out
and how many businesses please
so in the region of 22 million
has been paid out so far and that is to
over
that's been in over 2 000 grants to
multiple businesses across the district
thank you very much thank you councillor
smith again thank you councillor belton
and can i also just say what's a
tremendous
effort that has been over the past year
to support local businesses
and indeed i would like to pay tribute
to officers that
were some of the fastest in the county
probably some of the fastest in the
country to ensure that our businesses
were supported financially with the uh
central government funds that really is
appreciated because it
means an awful lot to the businesses and
an incredible sum of money that
had to be distributed through various
grant schemes so
thank you very much indeed okay right
um any other points or questions that
anyone wishes to make
no i can't see any which really takes us
to the
two recommendations of paragraphs 1.1
and 1.2
1.1 is that the council enters into a
framework agreement with essex county
council
and agrees to support the distribution
of specific
business grants to rochefort businesses
and the second recommendation of 1.2 is
that the assistant director place
and environment in consultation with the
portfolio holder for commercial
business local economy and leisure be
given delegated authority to agree
minor additions or amendments to these
agreements in the interest
of facilitating a quick and effective
grant program
for local businesses now members i will
move the two recommendations do i have a
secular please
i'll second that chairman thank you
thank you thank you councillor
members um are you happy to vote on
these two recommendations together
i will assume that you're in agreement
unless you click on the raised hand icon
and again i'm not seeing any frantic
waving or raising of uh
hands so we will take them together
please unmute yourself and advise me if
you're not able to use the electronic
hand and raise your hand
manually so it can be counted members if
anyone would like a recorded vote to be
taken
please click on your raised hand icon at
once
and again i'm not seeing any movement
there
so voting will be done by an electronic
show of hands
if i can ask all those in favor of the
recommendations please click
click on the race hand icon once please
do that now if you will please
again it's unanimous chairman
thank you sonya those two
recommendations
are both read um and uh
thank you very much
that then members concludes the business
for this evening's meeting
thank you very much indeed for attending
and
at 1942 by my computer
that closes the uh the meeting thank you
very much
indeed
thank you thank you good night i'm going
to keep that running for you um
thank you good night
can we get danielle back
yes i've got that icon
yeah it needs to be switched off
i'm just going to give sonya a call and
ask her to dial us out
please
[Music]
says we've got four people watching but
one of those is me
three people watching
so
three
uh
um
do
hmm
let's move to a single view of arthur
now